[Music]
los santos
a city gone to hell filled with drug
running
bank heists and a taco trap house a guy
can't even go for a sunday drive without
getting attacked
oh my god
they're all running around terrorizing
this damn city holding everyone hostage
out of fear of retaliation
but everything would have been fine if
it wasn't for those
damn lean boys
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh jesus
so the lean boys are a fictional gang
that exists within grand theft auto 5
rp and rp is just a modded version of
gta where you role play as whoever the
hell you want
you could be a mailman an old man with
dementia who runs for mayor or
if you're lyric a bumbling drug dealing
criminal named after a character from
the wire
suicide pill
[Music]
by the time the lean boys were founded
both gta rp
and no pixel which is the server the
lean boys eventually called home
had been around for quite a few years
and while gta rp
is violent ridiculous and over the top
it only works because the people who
participate
commit to the bit the more you commit
the more engaging the experience is for
everyone involved
oh [ __ ] they got everything they left
the notes here too
now lyric needed to make some money so
naturally
he turned to a life of crime but every
aspiring criminal
needs a crew and before he knew it
lyric's character avon barksdale
fell in with some fellow psychopaths
looking for a gig
i'm a felon man i'm a felon right you
actually shouldn't even be talking to me
right now but
um you uh you know uh lang here
buddhalang and bob you know them i know
we're setting up a highway earlier
setting up a little bank
heist you know what i'm saying see at
first
lyric just wanted to rob a bank snag
some cash and set up his criminal empire
but on the ride over he spotted some
surfer
dude who apparently had snitched on yo
get in the car right now
get the [ __ ] in the car don't even run
they kidnapped the loose lit beach bum
iced him in the back of a meat locker
and then went on a high-speed chase
after a routine traffic stop went
horribly wrong
mr barksdale would you mind stepping out
of the vehicle for me sir what is the
pineapple
pineapple pineapple what the [ __ ] you
shot at him
oh my [ __ ] yeah i shot at him and
that
was just day one we're all in this
together
i have a question real quick what's the
gang's name
by the way establish it the lean boys
no the original members of the lean boys
are what i would call
a loose collection of maniacs you've got
streamer buddha rpg as lang buddha
a former member of a chinese triad
anthony z is tony corleone
a wisecracking gangster that moved to
los santos from liberty city
coolidge as bob coolidge buddha's grove
street neighbor
and saab as al saab a nice rich kid who
turned to a life of crime
and after all of that initial insanity
the lean boys doubled down they spent
the next couple of years
leaning dealing drugs beefing with other
gangs
all while trying and often failing to
rob
whatever they could get their hands on
going
away from the building i know you're
near go to your go to your cop car
go to your why are you so close to the
building i told you not to be close to
the building
and one of the more notorious situations
is the 18-hour war that popped off
with rival crosstown gang the chang
down oh my gang we're talking to our
points
that was a good fight we're in a bad
spot to be honest the dumpsters and [ __ ]
were really good on them
for a while the lean boys and the chang
gang were as friendly as two gangs could
be
but before long [ __ ] hit the fan
the lean boys gunned down various chang
gang associates
i guess we're not gonna talk the chang
gang stabbed al
sab saab atop mount chiliad
and friends of both gangs were openly
gunned down in the street
a brief ceasefire was eventually
negotiated but then eugene zuckerberg
had to just go and open his
mouth and kick off a war that lasted 18
hours
role played by twitch streamer vader
eugene is an old man who uses his
dementia as an excuse to commit crimes
he's a beloved figure in the gta rp
community
and a one-time member of the lean boys
and during one of his senile stupors
eugene leaked the location of a chang
gang warehouse
so in response they kidnapped eugene and
other members of the lean boys and
straight up murdered them
i did nothing violent to you at all keep
my [ __ ] name out of your [ __ ]
mouth next time
after that all bets were off these two
very fake gangs
went to war good boy
[Music]
why lightning
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i got one i got one oh yes a tyrone
here
i i love you take this
[Laughter]
the two separate fights that sprawled
across different parts of los santos
took
no prisoners drive-bys during the day
would turn into
long extended convenience store
shootouts at night
and running throughout all of this
cartoonish violence is the commentary
from the streamers themselves
which adds this like absurdist narrative
quality to the whole thing
um do you know what this is about
because i'm a little nervous
not really new apparently a war
i don't know what the war was oh maybe
it's like a truce
maybe like they want the war to end in
truth
now while the lean boys did their best
to claim revenge and victory over the
chang gang
ultimately they got their asses kicked
and were forced to surrender
calling for peace talks over the radio
and after going back and forth for an
hour at the los santos airport with
offers and counter offers
the lean boys and the chang gang came to
an agreement signing peace contracts
that signal the end of their latest
bloody battle
final 2 million
for the culver sack all right warehouse
comedy club tony spaghetti shop
and no job
but you stay out of the beef the curds
are flipping no matter how hard are they
gonna try to stay out of the bean
now sure the shootouts and bank heists
that happen throughout gtrp
are exciting but they aren't what gives
the role-playing experience its identity
no what makes these fictional fights so
engaging to watch
are the narratives surrounding them i'm
not saying anything new here this is
true of any role-playing experience
dragons and orcs aren't that much fun to
fight if you don't care about who's
wielding the sword
and the same goes for fictional gang
wars i think
alright you guys can stay safe i love
you bros all right
oh [ __ ] oh
[Music]
oh